I want you to tell me how to stay poor
you're like hey brain tell me how to
destroy my business number one is start
tomorrow whatever it is that's a good
one just start tomorrow number two read
books do nothing so just keep reading
take no action it's the best way to just
stay poor next one take advice from poor
people on how to get rich all your
friends report you should totally listen
to them on how to get rich because
they've never achieved it so you should
listen to them number four how to say
four pick a spouse who makes you feel
guilty about working oh man of course
you want to find somebody who supports
your goal who's either in it with you or
they're cheering you on from the
sidelines